The joe rogan experience series or
something along those lines. See,
that's an interesting, uh, I'm,
I'm absolutely convinced most of these
guys believe what they say now, Ma,
maybe they're bullshitters at the start
or they only partially believe, but they,
they repeat their rhetoric,
their followers, giving
them positive reinforcement.
They come to believe it. And,
uh, you know, David Koresh,
he was right down the barrel. He totally
believed, willing to die for his beliefs.
And he also was having sex with
everybody. Yes. Yes. I mean,
it's so common.
It's almost cliche.
And his ex girlfriend grew up in one of
these sort of religious cults and it was
the same deal. The head guy was having
sex with all the women and you know,
he would have sex with different people's
wives and everybody had to let them,
yeah. Say do the fundamentalist Mormons.
Um, what's his name that's in jail now?
Jay. Jay. Jeffrey, Jeff,
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeffrey.
Jeff Jeffries is JB. I'm thinking of
Jim Jefferies, my friend, the comedian.
Uh, but anyway, yeah, that's, you
know, that's how it gets corrupted.
I don't know if you ever read John.
Um,
John Crack hours book
under the banner of Heaven.
This is the guy that the mountain climber
that did a into thin air and, and uh,
and the, um, the one about
the Alaskan kid. Anyway,
he wrote this book called under the
banner of the Alaskan Kid who died. Yes.
When they made that movie about
that moving into the wild. Yeah.
So he did any of the wild into thin air.
Krakauer's a great writer. So this book,
he starts to investigate
the murder of this, um,
polygamous family in Utah,
just as a journalist.
He's going to do a story for
the New Yorker or something.
And then he realizes this takes them
down the path of this incredible world of
polygamy, which still goes on now legally.
It's not legal, but they marry one.
And then the others are so called sister
wives and they're just there and they
live on these, in these border towns along
the border between Colorado and Utah,
like Colorado city. And I've been
through some of these places. It's like,
it's like a twilight zone episode. You
go into this town gas station, whatever.
It's like, oh, it feels
kind of weird here. And, uh,
so Krakauer discovered this
whole world of, you know,
going all the way back to the
founding of the religion. And, um,
uh, what's the name?
Joseph Smith. And you know,
he gets this revelation
from God that, uh, well,
basically he's banging the woman
down the street, he's married.
And so he gets this revelation from God.
And Krakauer has this,
this scenario in the book where
he tells his wife, now, honey,
I've been talking to God and you're
not going to believe this, but he says,
I have to marry this, you know, so and
so down the street, she's like, oh yeah,
well I have to start
seeing other guide. No, no.
God was very specific about this.
It's just for the guys. And,
and how do I know you talked to him?
Well, my buddies, they were there.
They heard it also.
And this is the,
the first page of the book
of Mormon is an affidavit.
These are the people that heard the
revelation and there they all sign it.
And it's like, okay, so
this is how it starts.
And Joseph Smith started it all
off in 1820. He's only 14. Yes,
it's me. A 14 year old is not a liar.
That's right. They just learn that a lie.
It's an even like that. They're bad
people. When you're 14 years old,
you are a developing entity. You know,
your frontal lobes are not fully formed.
You don't really know what
you're practicing sentences,
you know what you're doing,
trying to exert your influence.
And this guy was just very creative.
He was,
and he got chased out of Palmyra.
New York is where he started.
And then he moved to Missouri
when basically he was in
trouble with the law and,
and other issues. And then he got in
trouble there and he was killed. And it,
usually, this ends a cult when the leader
dies. Now there's, there's a kind of a,
there's a critical period if you get
a new dynamic leader to take over.
Like in the case of Scientology,
um,
David Miscavige took over after l Ron
Hubbard passed over to the other side and,
uh, he managed to keep it going.
And same thing with Brigham Young.
It was bringing me young that turned this
little cult into a world religion and
they just went further west to Utah
to get away from federal authorities.
Now how much of a hit is
Scientology taking from that,
Leah Remini I don't,
we don't even,
I've not seen any data like a memberships
and they're all secret about that
anyway. It's proprietary data, so who
knows? I can't imagine they could survive.
Well, they could survive because they
have tons of money through real estate
investments,
but I can't imagine their numbers are or
could be doing anything but shrinking.
Yeah. Between the Lawrence Wright
book than the Hbo Documentary Feature.
Just crossed stuff crappy.
Yeah,
and your dialogue with with
Aaliyah was incredible. And cheese.
Just a hero amongst, you know, seculars
that fight against colts. That's really,
that's really the,
the best way to do it.
Not top down laws against cults
unless they're doing something.
He'll obviously illegal,
but just bottom up members speaking.
I had David Miscavige has dad
on as well. Right. That was,
that was sad.
That was sad because I felt like I was
talking to a guy who felt like he wasted
his life and lost his son.
Right.
And brought his son into Scientology.
The whole thing was that was
really disturbing. Yup. Just a,
it's just very strange that the United
States government is allowing those
people to be tax exempt. I mean, with
all the evidence that's available,
you just go and look at what they're
proposing and what they believe in the
Thetis and the frozens entities.
They're dropped into the volcano.
All the crazy shell, the
story about there, this is
what really worried me about,
um, the IRS. I mean, I've
always thought, you know,
I don't fear it hell or the devil,
but I fear the IRS, you know, I take,
I'm pretty careful about that,
but they're the only major organization
I've ever seen that beat the IRS.
And they did it through,
uh, thousands of lawsuits.
I think they sued him like
3,500 times or something. Well,
they sent every single member that they
could get to do it to them as well.
They were getting all their members
to sue it. They were suing. Right?
That was the story. Isn't
that how it worked? Yeah.
And then eventually the IRS just
said, okay, if I get your tax exempt,
I mean, if they're letting the Mormons
do it and why wouldn't they let the
scientologist? Yes sir. I really don't
think any religion shipped. I agree.
It's ridiculous. I agree. I mean in 2018
with what we know about reality, right?
The fact that we let some old voodoo
superstitious nonsense and not have to pay
taxes and exert extreme power politically,
socially,
economically, it's crazy. Well,
so, and they like preachers get up,
they can live in a house, tag three,
then you have to pay property tax on the,
on the home that they own.
You know?
So there's a lot of these side benefits
also that you don't normally hear about
gross.
So the freedom from religion foundation
and some of these other organisations,
ACLU or you know, trying to combat
some of this, but, but legally,
how do you distinguish that from say a
nonprofit like doctors without borders or
one of these other groups that Clinton
Foundation killing whales. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There was some statistic recently in
the Clinton Foundation how much money in
night in 2014 they actually
donate to cherry. Oh Christ.
It was like 6% something like
extremely low. The rest of it.
But payroll and yeah, mostly expenses.
Private mean that's what it is.
And they're scams. All these things
are scams. Yeah. It's just, yeah,
it might be good to just clean house and,
and just,
no one gets a new nonprofit status or
tax free status unless you're just,
well I don't know.
I mean I think,
I feel like there was room in the world
for compassionate charities that are
actual charities that
are really legitimate.
There's room in the world for them and
I think that they should have tax exempt
status, but I think we should
be really stringent. Right.
And about what we accept.
Um,
yeah.
Well the Supreme Court then they have a
PR problem is where do you draw the line?
You know, cause somebody says,
well I have a goofy belief.
The Jane's have some weird beliefs or
something, but you know, but their,
but their man in the soup kitchens,
they're helping the poor
and there's no corruption.
So w w what's the difference between
them and the Scientologists and say, Hey,
you know, we have our own
religious beliefs that to use
sound goofy, but you know,
to us their true.
What's the difference?
Well the Mormons are fascinating to me
because they do seem goofy when you look
at the idea that Joseph Smith,
who was a 14 year old found golden tablets
that contained a loss work of Jesus
and only he could read them cause
he had a magic seers stone, right?
And then when the local townspeople came
to see, well where are these stones?
All the angels came and took them away
because they do not believe like it's so
preposterous. But Mormons are
really nice people. Totally Nice.
They're the sweetest,
nicest way.
I think they've made the transition
from cult to religion, a religious sect.
And most, most Christians no
longer consider them a cult.
Some evangelicals do cause
they're pretty far out.
But most mainstream Christian said,
yeah, yeah, they're Christians.
I mean they accept Jesus as their savior
and that technically that gets you in
the club. They just got to
let all that Joseph Smith
stuff go. Yeah. Cause they're,
the way they treat people
is fantastic. I mean, yeah,
I'm not a big fan of them going to these
poor countries and proselytizing and
you know, getting these
vulnerable people to become part.
But I think the way they deal with
community and the way they deal with each
other, it's like a very, it's a very
warm and friendly and family environment.
And most of the Mormons that
I've met that are practicing,
I've been very nice people and they're,
and they're serious about their tithing
and the 10% I mean they have strict
rules about this, like capital gains.
Then it's a quilt on cafeteria.
So if you sell your
house and make a profit,
you got to give 10% of that to church,
not just your income,
not just your paycheck. Yeah. And they,
they're pretty, pretty strict about that.
And I'm a, and the
money, as far as I know,
mostly goes for good causes that
really does help poor people
[inaudible]
okay.